>> Will China pull us out of the economic
crisis? I don't really think so. I think it
will pull itself out of the economic crisis
since it's doing a very good job of that but
more or less, each country needs to deal with
its own problems. They can export, they can
benefit from what other people are doing,
but in the end you can't rely on some other
country to do it for you. So China's mission
and China's attention most properly is going
to be focused on getting itself out of the
economic crisis. The rest of the world needs
to look at China and understand that the Chinese
economy is going to be larger then every other
economy in the foreseeable future because
it's such a large country. But the goal of
economic success is not to be bigger then
China. It's to be appropriate to your own
population. So China is going to be a bigger
and bigger part of the world but each country
has to do it's own bit.